[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission Ça ne savent
décolle la Réunion ensemble vous allez
paraît alors allons-nous
[Musique]
dans la commune de Saint-Pierre plus
précisément à mon verre et nous ne
savent découvre le site du python mont
vert car c'est un espace naturel
sensible allez allons-nous
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur
comment allez bien alors
ben moi travaille avec l'association
hommes d'armes nous les gestionnaires du
site du python vert
c'est la propriété du département donc
ça fait à peu près 18 ans que nous fait
un travail de lutte contre les espèces
exotiques et du préparation du terrain
pour la replantation et d'ailleurs nous
on a une serre aussi pour les vaches des
plans ok ici que ça nous peut retrouver
un peu comme espèce envahissant du
colossil lutte contre une prédominance
bah du faux poivrier ou alors plus
communément aussi appelé béroze donc
c'est à dire que le beros une a aussi
une importance pour l'apiculteur pour
les abeilles etc donc ne peut pas tout
enlever d'un coup dans 5 que 10 ans on
aura des espèces endémiques voire
indigènes des espèces médifères que sera
maturité et les fleurs va pouvoir servir
de nourriture pour les abeilles donc
d'un emplacement que les sur l'autre
flanc de Python donc les prêts à
accueillir un rucher génial
[Musique]
ça va bien Victor
enchanté alors c'est original je vois
que vous avez fait la petite balade en
bas c'est pas très compliqué donc ouais
on s'est permis de le faire en tong
c'était pas très glissant et pourquoi
vous avez décidé de devenir fait cette
balade là du coup alors si vous savez on
était dans un gîte à côté qu'on pouvait
qu'on pouvait venir faire la petite
randonnée qui est durée à 15-20 minutes
ok c'était la petite sortie de la
matinée du coup quand vous venez vous
promener dans la forêt là qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous venez rechercher bah
le point de vue le calme bon on se
bouger un peu les fesses quand même pour
faire un peu de sport voilà et bah des
gars profitez du point de vue moi j'ai
continué par là on la trouve ciao ciao
[Musique]
à 636 mètres d'altitude alors
il dit que c'est un volcan en a entre 20
et 25000 ans il paraît que quand le
volcana éruption là il a coule entre la
ravine de CAF et la ravine de Lens il
devait être vraiment impressionnant et
ben nous nous continuons de boucle pour
nous arrive à notre point de départ
allez la réunion nous les la même mon
pays comment il est la réunion s'amène
parle pas nous aller nous verrez la même
un peu le respect pour mon pays il avait
vraiment après depuis son lit au bout de
la terre non pas dit faut comprendre
fort à deux mots de mon pays la réunion
nous les la même mon pays comment il est
la réunion s'amène
respect pour mon pays vraiment d'après
depuis ce livre bonjour mesdames bonjour
monsieur comment il est là bonjour
madame tu peux fatigué
ou bien même six ans
aussi comme le travail pas trop et
est-ce que les sentiers que tu fais
notamment c'est toujours aujourd'hui ou
ça se fait habituellement est-ce que
toutes les sorties des professionnels
on ramène chez vous comme nous nous
mettent toujours dans notre salle nous
ramène chez nous donc si tout le monde
fait comme ça c'est bon j'ai soif
[Musique]
et nous les gestionnaires de cet espace
naturel sensibles depuis 2004 et en tant
que gestionnaire on a cinq grandes
missions mais et en plus dans ces cinq
grandes missions là nous on a une
mission c'est la prospérité l'élevage la
plantation de plantes endémiques et
indigènes sur le python mont vert et
aussi parce que finalement nous
contribue au plan un million d'arbres du
département d'accord voilà donc pas si
tu connais mais ce plan un million
d'Arabes là il tu as remplacé plus ou
moins tout bonnes espèces exotiques que
les déplantée dans les villes tout ça et
chez les particuliers et d'autant plus
aussi sur les espaces naturels sensibles
que le département la mette en place OK
et pourquoi un million de bois puisque
aller nous dire la Réunion on en a à peu
près 800 et quelques milles habitantes
donc
il semblerait que le président la
décider un chiffre fort un million plein
énorme et Nova dire tant mieux sinon
arrive le 1 million c'est l'objectif
mais sinon réunis 180 000 représente
quand même au moins un pied de bois par
habitant donc le challenge c'est réussi
déjà en tout cas
[Musique]
voilà des petites balades autour du
python mon verre nous l'a vu c'était un
volcan ok la réunion les gaillard allons
pour le temps vis-à-vis et pour ça
rendez vous à la prochaine épisode de
l'émission à nous cette fois-ci sera
dans la commune de La Possession à mafat
il va y découvre il est à malheur
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]